all right bootleg cab show we got a
special guest in here
the
so bootleg cab so listen everybody i
want to share
what's going on in my life so bootleg
have my um
been trying to get me on the air yeah
for the last few months and
when i found out i was coming to town i
said okay cool uh i'll do it so i had
another interview with sway this morning
so i'm still not paying attention right
so i get here and i sit there because
i'm waiting for
bootleg cab to come in right right so
i'm sitting out in the lobby all this
time waiting for
bootleg cab to come in because i never
knew it was him
and i never thought he was white i
thought he was this black guy from the
last show
when we did it over there
so that's why i came as i went to the i
went to the brother coming in you know
i'm not going to sit
so i'm chilling you know and i said when
bootleg cab come because i had to go get
chips in the soda and he was like yo
when's your guy getting here i'm like
which guy
he's like kev i'm like i'm old school
i'm like where the [ __ ] are my snacks
like you know i'm old school like see
back in the real estate back in the day
they have donuts they have chips for you
they carry you they they're just an
independent operation when i came i said
you know when bootleg cab
i want my four dollars back for my my
chips and my soda he made you pay for
the chips i paid for the chicken
it's a vending machine in the lobby so
my point again is
i did not know
bootleg cab was a white guy ladies and
gentlemen i think a lot of people don't
know for some reason i thought it was a
black dude that i was waiting on well
not at all and you know me and your son
are really good friends and i'm like yes
and i didn't know it was a white guy and
the last time you did our show it was
because your son
my son is hooked up all the stuff but i
thought the black dude was bootleg cab
dj so when i saw dj head today you were
like
no no i thought he was somebody totally
different
because i was like yo i know you he said
yeah you um
you you did something with me and your
son but i couldn't put two and two
together now it all come full circle
there it is he was there at this radio
station you was there i'm thinking it
was his show at that time yeah we had a
show together the show together yeah
that's where the confusion came that's
some funny [ __ ] that made my dad well
there's another brother here now james
andre we don't really care about him
and let me tell you why because he got
to earn his strengths he's a young comic
yes and we make young comics we got to
be hard on them right right so that way
when they when they get to that certain
level they sit down and yeah then the
tikka kirkland and
he gave me my flowers but [ __ ] kept it
real you know he's totally [ __ ]
love and it's because of him it's where
i am today
shout out to tk kirkland
oh that's what happens that happens a
lot that's not what you talk about
that's what happens when you get when
comedians like him get old and they blow
up they start talking about how the
become a multi-millionaire actor and all
that and he'll talk about this moment
you remember telling your name
that was that big big game and tk kirk
was there and you know and it's
something what he said inspired me and
then i just went on from there and just
took it in
the region's history is that is that
your young comic voice or is that just
specifically made i'm just making it
whoever the other person is
um you're here obviously you're a
legendary comedian i feel like comedy
has been in an extremely interesting
space uh in the last four or five years
in terms of like
you know free speech
yeah you know people being offended
because i feel like you know comedians
in general like we kind of look to
comedians to say the [ __ ] that we can't
say right right right to to make light
of certain situations that maybe there
is no light in right
where do you feel like the
comedy game is right now do you like
where it's at i know there's a lot of
dope up and coming young community you
have to be smart like if you work for
somebody you have sponsors you work for
somebody
you have to protect your money because
the goal to do this business is to
get paid right not to put yourself in
the position
to defuse yourself i'm gonna speak my
mind cause then you're not a businessman
right
see if you're a businessman you gotta
fall back cause don't nobody everybody
claims to say oh yo you kept it real
are you here for the people
but i think 20 30 years from now when
your ass is old and bro and you ain't
broke and you need something i'm saying
people that said keep it you did right
ain't going to be by your side right
you got to adapt
so do do you got it you got to be a
businessman what are your thoughts on uh
this whole joe rogan controversy that's
been happening in the last couple i
thought it was interesting they gave him
a hard time but it goes to show you how
they are really behind him and they
really respect him you know because if
it was anybody else even a step
underneath him
[Music]
it had been over
like in terms of like obviously he's had
a very successful podcast you have a
successful podcast
um
he's kind of looked at as like someone
who's helped a lot of comedians with his
platform over the years i'm quite sure
he has yeah i'm i'm going back i'm gonna
try to get on joe rogan this year but
um
you can't miss him because his name is
everywhere even before the
the the word end letter n in the kovic
situation i just believe unless you're a
doctor i think it should stay away from
kovic issues um
i mean the tape is the tape but the tape
is the tape
why isn't the tape um
used against this person when you have
the tape here's a different story
but there's tape but you have tape you
see it
so is there anything it can't be good
for you one person not good for the
other person right do you think like
because my thing is is like do you think
you know i think that me and james
talked about this just in in general any
use of the n-word is out if you're not a
black person yeah absolutely it's a code
right blackboard yeah black people's we
could use it there are certain like
comedians you can use it around your
friends but not to well like there's
like certain guys like louis c.k who's
used it
right in front of chris rock that one
time on hbo thing um is there any sort
of like
rule
rule with the comedian [ __ ] like does
comedy leave it wide open if there's a
certain context involved you think yeah
because i say [ __ ] all the time i mean
but you you can say that yeah i say
[ __ ] all the time um
but believe it or not when i get off
stage i don't use profanity at all at
all at all i don't curse at all when i'm
off stage i slow down a little bit
that's crazy yeah i don't do i don't do
no
profanity whatsoever
so um
the n word is based on your audience the
n word is based around who who you're
around the n-word is based on um
you're feeling comfortable
saying it and like i said and everything
is about choices and common sense of
course so truly some black people don't
even sound right saying it because yeah
who said that it's black dude yeah so
that's definitely true so um
[Music]
we live in a strange time man
you know the world changed that's why
bill cosby got caught up right
the world changed it was like he
committed to crime today mm-hmm the
world changed he still happened to be
still alive and got caught up in in the
bs
right so
it comes you know they said you're going
high but so long what caught up with
them
do you think someone like joe rogan
should be cancelled quote unquote cancer
he should be cancer but because he
didn't get cancer you look like a fool
saying he should get cancer when he
stood the storm right um
what's my man the rock yeah that was
against him
because everybody thought
everyone came after the rock and then
the rock retracted his stance so he did
retract yeah yeah
well because originally he had posted in
support of him right but then i'm saying
he did he retracted after the last one
no he retracted i think his support for
jordan right right right put a tweet out
pretty much saying just like hey now i
know the full narrative right right
right and it still doesn't take away
from cause there's a tape there's yes
right see i see they can say that
see if there wasn't a tape
again
this conversation would be different
then you could you say oh he's not
racist but you saw the tape
so even though when you first seen it
even though even even though we
have a tendency to overreact
society overreacts online especially
nowadays right especially nowadays we
overreact and
joe is a nice i'm quite sure he's not
known but i'm quite sure is the
overreaction i didn't see the tape
everything i'm hearing talk about right
now is just really hearsay but i do know
there was a tape and i i just want the
tape to be consistent with everybody
right
if i saw you doing something on the tape
that's the tape like it can't be good
for you but then something else happens
right it's not good for you i think
that's wrong that's fair that should be
a general just a general rule for it
just a general rule it has to be fair
for everybody but we know i i even in my
act i teach people not to be chilled you
know how you ever walk in the room and
someone gives you a bigger candy say oh
well we that's the black community
because when whites do something they
say oh he didn't get the same case
etc right but i tell people time that if
you read the um
[Music]
the law library and if you're in jail
if a black man and white man is arrested
it states in the book
that a white man can't get the same
charge as a black man
i mean that's something we've obviously
just seen right yeah yeah it's just it's
deep but um
what i try to teach people is just the
right way the world right and like even
when they talk about racism say i
believe racism will always exist
i think people can't get along right but
we can respect each other see there's a
difference i mean we may men like each
other but i'm still going to be if
people start saying this in racism
we're never going to end that that's
impossible because that's
a very unrealistic it's unrealistic but
we can respect each other
i can respect you
you can do that
see so they need to change it to
we're going to respect each other to say
let's end racism
i think it changes the whole game
yeah i think ending racism is a great
thought right right it sounds like
cotton candy but it's when there's so
many variables so many where are you
where you might be raised
you were
raised um
no matter what everyone has a certain
amount
of prejudice that is even subconscious
yes right they're just sitting there but
that doesn't mean that like your hate
like they're like i think everyone has a
certain amount of uh subconscious
stereotype about people yes or prejudice
about people like you said it's a matter
of respect it's a matter of like
are you a hateful person right are you
and see you can still be hateful
that's how powerful respect is respect
is so powerful that i could still i
could hate the [ __ ] out you
but i respect you so much you know
michelle i mean that happens a lot in
prison yeah listen between between races
like you gotta you gotta respect it's
like if we were talking in jail
and somebody came up and interrupted us
without saying excuse me or waiting they
turn you have a problem
i apply the same rules to life it's not
like
i've gone to prison for a long time the
rule is i'm so into respect
but when you're in this world today and
me being much older i have because of
wisdom i kind of have to change my
thought a little because i'll always be
an argument like i don't believe you
should be up close to me when we're in
line of course i believe you should have
that space
prior to covet by the way prior to kobe
give me some give me three feet [ __ ]
space so what i used to do
when i see somebody too close i always
take my backpack and throw it on my
shoulder and hit him by accident like oh
i'm sorry you're here get the obviously
you're two no for real like i'm for real
with that [ __ ] right before calling it
give me three feet yeah like why are you
up on me yeah oh i'll tell a person a
female if she's too close or um getting
to pay a bill so you're getting close
we're gonna we're gonna be in the
relationship um
step the [ __ ] back
there's nothing wrong with so my way of
thinking is so
uh manly and respectful and so um
traditional but the world is not like
that i'm angry every day and i have to
keep it to myself
i'm angry
every day now let that [ __ ] out man no
no no no no you can't do that she's
gonna end up on [ __ ] tmz yeah you
they're going to try to cancel him you
got to learn let's say i get the best
what i'm learning is um
bite my tongue a little bit see
everybody feels like everybody wants to
be a um this quote quote leader right
right
and you can't save the world
you cannot save the world can i say the
word that's facts right you gotta save
your peace though yeah you gotta save
your peace you can take you can teach
your close children around you
but you can't save the world you talked
about just you're more of a traditional
guy right and it feels like in 2022
there's been kind of like a campaign
against
being a traditional guy oh yes sir right
oh my god
see
because
in actuality i should be off the market
right
say i should be kind of retired
i should be married
but because of the way i think
i sound old-fashioned to the world if i
was about talking to a young lady i give
her
my opinion on life and they look at me
like a [ __ ] crazy you know or
i had a comment the other day
um
where i told
on the air that men should have 25 000
in their account
before they start [ __ ] before they
start dating
well uneducated and i'mma say exactly
the uneducated people was hitting me in
my dm talk about you ugly [ __ ]
you just cause you ugly uh a young [ __ ]
who ain't got no money
could be [ __ ] all day these are the
stories i'm getting watch where i'm
going they missed the whole point they
missed the whole [ __ ] point
like i'm a player
i'll never give a [ __ ] 25 [ __ ] a
thousand dollars what i'm telling people
is have your [ __ ] together before you
approach a woman because to the people
who's gonna listen to this let me give
you some gang some good game
see when your money right your choices
of hoes is different
see when you broke then you [ __ ] with
taco bell type [ __ ]
see when you ain't got your money right
you [ __ ] with [ __ ] uh hotdog
wienerschnitzel type [ __ ] but when
your money is right your choices is
different you move differently your
options and your options
everything is [ __ ] different so to
all the people who
was listening and commenting on the
stuff that i said on the breakfast club
i wasn't offended by it it showed me how
uneducated the world is
i've never taught any man
to give any money to a female what i'm
saying is
stop [ __ ] broke and nothing in
[ __ ] and then
babies raised yeah they come out here
can't afford having
shooting and killing everybody that you
can't take care of the child
you see you over you totally overlook
what the [ __ ] i was saying excuse me for
using a family kind of curse
i really want them to understand what
i'm saying right right like you
you're dumb i'm gonna say you dumb
[ __ ] who raised you like i'm
for real with that [ __ ] like it's
you nuttin in the [ __ ] and your money
ain't right
girl come back pregnant and now you're
gonna blame her that she got pregnant
money ain't right you can't take care of
kid can't put a kid in daycare can't
even [ __ ] pay for the abortion if you
can't even pay for the abortion yeah but
because you think you're handsome you
can nothing a [ __ ] cause you ain't got
25. i've had a [ __ ] i got five
thousand dollar and i [ __ ] just like you
rich guys
missing the point
that's the more ego an egotistical way
of looking at it
a child like that's like a 19 year old's
perspective like man i'm out here
[ __ ] [ __ ] exactly don't matter
exactly but when i was giving them game
that's real getting some real [ __ ]
money right because you
it won't you won't be a nine ninety
percent of the time you won't be a liar
also twenty five thousand dollars i
don't know i'm gonna say this foreign
you won't be a liar watch what i'm
saying
most men lie because they ain't got no
money so they lie the [ __ ] to pretend
to be something that they're not
but your money right you still could be
[ __ ] up in here sick
but guess what i'd rather for men have
money
than to be egotistical
with money i remember egotistical money
than not to have money is what i mean
because when you don't have money you
got low self-esteem you're a liar i'd
rather for a man to be a little cocky
because i hate weak men i hate wine
there's a lot of men whine to get [ __ ]
because they complain all the time so
[ __ ] give me some personally because
she feels sorry for you not because you
gave her now as long as cause you put up
on game
some guys get [ __ ] because they gave a
[ __ ] a bag about a diamond bracelet
right but did you take time to see the
[ __ ] character um
see every fine girl you see you gotta
ask yourself somebody just see her let
me pause for a second
check out her character and see what
kind of substance she has as a woman
what kind of vocabulary she is she soft
when i talk to her or do i feel like i'm
talking to a man that just got a fat ass
and she's cute
you know because a real man won a woman
who's soft you're on the phone talking
to her late at night does she make you
feel good because of the tone of her
voice
or she's her vocabulary oh my god what's
she talking about
using
using vocal like [ __ ] talk you feel
like you're talking to your homie right
you know what i'm saying
she's gonna sound nothing like a lady
there's definitely a a group of women
that are so beautiful until they open
their mouth and you're like [ __ ] yes sir
it sounds like a mechanic in this video
yes you understand so you understand
what i'm saying so make sure i want to
make sure this segment is to the world
because it's so important for them to
understand what i mean and for how it's
important to have a soft woman
that you could talk to it changes
everything hey whatever we got to stop
the podcast real quick shout out to my
bookie man listen if you know anything
about me you know i like to gamble on
sports and i've been using my bookie for
so long go to mybookie.ag check it out
they're doing the my bookie double
deposit bonus this is how this works
you sign up you make a deposit you use
the promo code bootleg
and you're gonna get double your money
they're gonna match your deposit up to a
thousand dollars there's so much action
right now too the nba season is going
crazy
maybe you could do a future right who do
you think's going to win the mvp i don't
know is it going to be honest is it
going to be devin booker is it going to
be jokic
certainly ain't going to be
[ __ ] russell westbrook
crazy odds that ain't gonna happen
that's just burning money with that
being said there's so many different
ways you can bet you can bet on your
daily games you can do the parlay i like
doing money line parlays i like to just
do three or four heavy favorites on that
nba schedule throw them all on one
ticket and and just try to hit you know
what i'm saying whatever you're into my
bookie you can bet on it anything go to
mybookie.ag they got the double deposit
bonus right now this is important sign
up for an account make a deposit and
they will match your deposit double your
money up to a thousand dollars right now
that's free money so what are you doing
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up and you can double your money get in
on some of this nba action man it's nba
season all-star games this weekend so
much to i mean you could bet on the
three-point contest the [ __ ]
dunk contest whatever the [ __ ] is going
on who's gonna be the mvp of the
all-star game i don't know but you could
bet on it you could bet on anything so
make sure one more time that's my bookie
double your first deposit up two
thousand dollars using that promo code
bootleg place your bets what are we
doing bet on anything anytime anywhere
with my booking [ __ ] let's go i
remember one time i was in jersey my
hometown jerry city and i did a show and
a [ __ ] was finding a [ __ ] after
the show but her vocabulary she thought
she was a dude
we was at the bar right after after my
after party
and she was cursing i said you can yo
baby no mom you curse a little too much
this is what she said oh you don't know
who i am people you're just talking like
a [ __ ] like this
her turf
it got so bad like i had to leave
because somehow there was a
misunderstanding
that it was like it was about to go to
war
wow i had to leave
the other night i did a show at the
stress factory in um jersey
it was just a misunderstanding i came in
the ladies acting crazy and i couldn't
see because of the lights of my yeah i
said okay hoes okay house you know being
funny but they took it too serious but
there was a female who was the alpha
male
she controlled the energy of the other
females so when she felt disrespected
they all ever else felt disrespected
even at the show
um we were talking the conversation was
getting a little heated because she this
is someone in the crowder
in the crowd she was acting like a dude
she had men
qualities i said you a gang member i had
accident
she got offended but [ __ ] i meant what
i said because you acting like a man
so when i when she left all the ladies
and us was cool
i said hey come back tomorrow because i
think this went off the wrong way i'm
gonna make sure y'all get tickets
tomorrow i'm gonna take but they didn't
come and being on this earth long enough
i know is because the female who thought
she was a man
still felt defended maybe she identified
as a man listen to me you know i've been
around so long that i know this young
lady felt like she was a dude she got
men quality she gonna hung around men
so long that she don't picked up their
ways and that's another behalf we talk
about
men um
dress them like women or acting like
women
but we got women who are still women
who pick up the behavior of men
they mindset the way they move
it's like a man
there's nothing feminine about it except
the makeup the eyelashes
but they move like a dude they think
like a dude
and then they wonder why they get
cheated on they wonder why um they can't
keep a relationship because don't get me
wrong man they're not in you all day you
got a fat ass you're cute
but baby are you soft i don't feel the
softness huh
you know even this rolling up a blunt
you know and people do this today oh
yeah i just think the the women who roll
backward better than me is a lot i've
run into them often yes yes yes
to me
and because i'm older i think it's wrong
i mean that's the way you young you
young men move today i don't know i'm
just against it me
right i think that it's a generational
thing too because i think a lot of women
in
like that are
being raised in this generation by
younger people are are raised
in a very uh
hustler mind state everything's kind of
like a come up if we think about what's
gonna do with rolling weed no i don't i
just mean in terms of like um
you know
at least
you know when i do when i when i dj gigs
or like just some of the people who i'm
around like i'm like a lot of women are
like you said they have that mentality
that when we were growing up we had but
their mentality is like how can i hit a
lick on this dude or how can i you know
only fans just pop in like women are
like very much you mean hustle so i was
getting money getting money i'm still we
still talk about two different things
yeah hustling personality is two
different things fair enough hustling is
hustling you know i'm not against a
woman hustling because you still can be
a lady
in hustle
you ain't gotta act like a dude
to hustle
you ain't gotta
have your parents sag ain't gotta
talk reckless
to still hustle just gotta know how to
hustle right well if a woman sagging her
pants she might just be a lesbian right
but i'm just using yeah i'm just using
an example like you still can have a
dress on and be a hustler no for sure
right you still could be i'm just
talking about the softness of a woman
now this is going to go over a lot of
people's heads something like he's he's
sexist and all this
and i might be
it's because i'm in my 60s
so by the way you look great black don't
cry no black crack i just take care of
myself
40 years old yeah so that's my thing too
people think i look young
but i'm in i'm in my 60s your
perspective is a little different it's a
little different so i'm what i'm saying
is i respect
i'm smart enough to know that my way of
thinking is probably old and is what it
is right and i'm gonna deal with that
and i know i can't change the world so
i'm man enough to
um
laid back
and almost throw my cape on because i
had my time right i had i lived my life
and all i can do is put the gems out
there for some people with the graphs on
because you still can take what i've
talked about and apply it to your life
you still can take a young lady
and still make her soft and still know
she could still hustle still know that
she could still do great things as a
woman
instead of being with a man and act like
you don't want a man to feel like he's
with another man well this is also your
perspective so for people who get their
panties in a bunch it's like yo you're
speaking your truth yes but we know how
that is like
it's crazy how people don't respect
another person's opinion right but that
first thing you said was like you
respected like you sit back you know
you're 60 and you you think the way you
think you understand people think right
so that's a good way to think because
some people get upset when they see this
oh my god
like 65 just going crazy or what a bunch
of dudes is doing playing pokemon like
one right yeah it's just like it's wild
that just have that that perspective of
i understand that you think differently
in this yeah yeah you got to be smart
enough to understand so i understand you
know i just want to share to the world
um
just my
my take and perspective on these things
that's all that's fair and i think there
is something to be said about
why
certain i know a lot of women
that are single in their 30s
because they conducted themselves a
certain way throughout all their 20s yes
and now they're just kind of bitter
right right i think that's why people
kind of love kevin samuel so much right
because he kind of holds
everyone over the fire right right
and and even on the other end of the
spectrum so we're not being sexist here
like you said about the men having 25
grand before they start [ __ ]
imagine
you're 20 years old that you got no
money to your name and all of your
effort and anything you apply yourself
to is just getting [ __ ] you're going to
be broke for the rest of your life
thing that's good and what you're saying
is right so here's the answer to that
just like when you're young you
ambitious buy a car you're ambitious to
buy a house i want men to be ambitious
to save money not to get to the female
so let me stack my money so i'm right
before i go
to the female
because when you confidently got a
little bit of change like i said your
choices of women is different and it
based on generation right based on
parents parents should teach their kids
hey start stacking your money start
doing this start doing this um
when they're really a young person
because most parents wear to their child
is 18 says hey you on your own gotta get
a job figure it out and you figure it
out at 18 when you hit mine you had 18
years to really prepare for me to have
something when i walk out this door you
left your mind you got me at zero so
from 18 now i gotta catch up
with life but we had 18 years like can
you imagine somebody put
100 200 a month away in something for 18
years or your child
like when they get 18 you have something
to put in their hand but most of us are
at zero at 18. or even just like kids
who
you know a lot of kids who are 15 16
any extra money that they get goes to
like
gaming or like yes right yeah some [ __ ]
it's like yo just right so when people
hear me it's not unrealistic but if you
get that mindset right start getting it
right you can get your money and it's
really not for
anybody over 14 right it's this this
the mindset is for people really young
because those are the people who are
really listening to me these are people
in my dm time i thank you like an uncle
you like a dad
that i never had to give a game i'm
going to pursue this because we don't
want young men to keep having babies
right right yeah i think too like it's
very important to understand that like
if you're going to be successful at
anything
energy is very important time is your
biggest currency that you have biggest
currency you have so if you're going to
try to be successful in this life and
you come out the gate 18 19 20 21 years
old and like one of your top three
priorities is getting laid every weekend
exactly you're running with one leg
exactly in this race and then some men
shoot themselves in the foot because
they have a baby two or three and they
have before 25. and that's where it's
like okay what are you doing
what do you realistically expect to
happen with your life now right
you said you you dug your own grades
because most people aren't extremely
blessed with like an insane talent that
transcends right and even if you are the
chances of that actually you cutting
through so much luck is involved so much
so much and so much hard work that you
might not even have time to put in now
because you got to worry about feeding
three kids right that's so true what
about uh marriage at a young age like is
that cutting yourself i think it's the
worst thing in the world but some people
could pull off he pulled it off
um i mean i'm 35 so yeah he's still
young yeah okay yeah still a youngster
but
it's good for some people except because
sometimes marrying somebody can motivate
you because right now you're not married
you're single yes you've been married in
the past you've never been married never
been married never never proposed or
nothing like that no no that's corny as
hell to me
yeah how many children do you have i
have seven how many baby mamas seven oh
so yourself
yeah three three three one night stands
seven children and i've made love to
some of the most beautiful women in the
world but i nutted
in the most seven unsuccessful [ __ ]
the world has ever seen
hmm yeah ain't nothing
ain't none of my baby mom is rich
so i wish one of them could have been
[ __ ] that's just a joke that's
gonna laugh that's funny [ __ ] but no
shout out to my kids moms but you know
my um
that life is for me like my oldest son
he's like dad i don't want to be like
you you know i want to have a family and
i said okay son well
have your own family and have your own
[ __ ] kids and you could have
everybody under one roof
the reason why i say this on the air is
that i want people to understand
to avoid depression you have to play the
hand that you dealt
see if you play your hand
and know who you are you're going to be
happy but when you start looking at
somebody else's [ __ ] or start
thinking well what if exactly then those
were you the problems come the issues
if you accept the hand that's given to
you and you just deal with it and look
forward yes
your happiness will be but like you said
when you start pocket watching other
people exactly people watching other
relationships people who you perceive to
be your peers yeah maybe in the same
field yes or you start dwelling too much
on
what could have happened yes what should
have happened yes then you're gonna
[ __ ] you're done right and it all
goes back to your nature like you said
earlier right we all get jealous we all
get angry right so i tell people control
your emotion it's one of the most if you
can train yourself over the years to
control your emotions
you won
that's real you won you have one i swear
to god because once you're in control
you still get the anger like
yeah but control your control that's why
i tell people to rest as much as you can
the night before because when you're not
well arrested you get angry easier
you'll snap at somebody you hurt
somebody because you didn't have proper
sleep the night before
so when people say hey
old people go to bed early you know i go
to bed early but i wake up i can go to
bed 10 o'clock still wake up before you
it's feel like i slept all day you know
that's because me i've worked so hard in
my whole life and got successful that i
just enjoy
life
like i like getting up early you can
start the whole my [ __ ] day because
this is i enjoy it well there's a
different energy i feel like uh when you
really finally grow up
you stop sleeping until like 11 a.m
right you start waking up before eight
you realize like
this like this like your
life your day just becomes so much more
productive right because look at what
you mean to yourself right you look
forward to doing this yeah this makes
you feel successful your wife knows
where you're going you feel good about
it
even when you talk to someone about what
you have
you may not realize but i'm telling you
what it sounds like
accomplishments
you accomplish something that's
motivating you own something you're
doing something yeah and i always tell
guys as you get old and you sit down
with a woman
when you start saying what you've done
and what you're about to do and not be
lying
it makes a woman [ __ ] way it makes it
interested in you because you have
accomplishments and that's what a man
should also look at the female okay babe
i see the fat ass
see the bad guys
where's your head at what have you
accomplished you're 30 something but
what have you account are you a real
estate agent did you graduate from
college do your own eyelash shop do you
do what do you own yeah what are your
aspirations what's your aspirations man
that's deep but that's what people
should look at it's a lot of
[ __ ] man right now i'm telling
you
is there a bare minimum because you said
uh a guy should be have 25k and it's not
really 25 000. for a female no no it's
really not the idea that 25k is more
like just have something just have
something it's just a metaphor i just
threw that number out what i'm saying
for females now this should be the same
same but have something right you know
like
a woman should have money not to give to
a man
right a woman should have money too that
she's with a guy really the way i came
up with this is two people had money
when they meet and it didn't work out
guess what the transition has got some
give me a place
you could play smooth if one person
broke
one's going to try to hold on to the
other person don't want to really leave
or
you're so [ __ ] up you're going to stay
you got to stay in the house because you
guys are both on the lease right you're
going to stay in a situation that's
because financially you don't have
another option no i have no i don't want
to go back to my mother's
right i don't want to go to my brother's
i can't go with my sister i burnt that
bridge
so i know it's hard to understand what
i'm saying but before you even put
yourself in that situation try to get
the money but you know what most 90
people do
they [ __ ] get the girl pregnant and then
they're behind the eight ball
that that's so crazy because you be
everything you said is real [ __ ] but
people take a little clip and just
make it this whole thing that you're not
saying like what you said about 25k
that's some real ass [ __ ] how do you get
the mailbox to me i mean how do you feel
about clips like like you had a hour
interview and everybody judges is off a
30-second clip how does that yeah yeah
yeah that's good i don't care you know
because we got platforms like this yeah
there's a contact stream yeah yeah yeah
you know
somebody's gonna hear the information
right and and and take it in yeah
somebody's going to hear it and there's
people already got the opinion of you
they're going to yeah and like i said
25 000 is just
my number it doesn't mean
realistically you have to have 25 right
have something when you say hello to
that young lady
you got something right what's that you
just got a couple thousand you're gonna
get a hotel room right you're gonna have
a little breakfast but you're gonna
nuttin her let's keep it real
a guy's gonna nut
how's she pregnant
then what
then what yeah some of you are gonna lie
and say give her the wrong name
some of y'all gonna curse up with her
[ __ ] they need my kid
and girls
go take it deeper you let a man get on
top of you and nothing you have a baby
but you know what no one never talks
about
how you can die giving birth that's real
and complications and if you don't love
a man
enough to get on that table see to have
a baby you should truly love a [ __ ]
that's a real [ __ ] because you could die
you see how many people get on the
[ __ ] i got pregnant you're gonna have
a baby and you don't even know nothing
about the man but you're gonna give them
risk your life
so you say don't [ __ ] unless you're
ready to die for that you got to love
them all about that that's why there's
gonna be people who's gonna who are
gonna be like well this guy's got seven
kids from seven babies
27 right
i didn't have kids in my 18 19 20 i am
at the 27. why do you think you never
got married or settled down um i've
always felt that
women mentally was petty
i mean okay this is you got something to
say yeah i i agree i mean listen based
on my experience with women in this
world yeah every woman is petty petty
yes i can't take it
i can't take the mood swings i can't
take an argument that you don't know
what you're arguing about oh my gosh
what welcome to mike i've been in a
relationship for 13 years i'm finally
proposed to my girl i i've been through
that yo i just wait i just had one of
those the other day where i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is going on or you buying
flowers for something that never
happened yes
yes you're buying flowers
for someone
an argument you have no [ __ ] idea
what happened you're just like here
right
shut the [ __ ] up yeah i'm the kind of
guy i don't mind a good argument if
there's subjects if there's something to
argue about yeah you break off into a
google's map there's over here
what happens a lot is i feel like women
people
uh
there'll be so much et cetera suppressed
anger about a bunch of little [ __ ]
that eventually there's just a fight
about
like we like you said we what are we
fighting about exactly it gotta make
sense yeah yeah like did if did i do
this if i did this i [ __ ] up that's my
bag and you can deal with it but let's
talk because you know what i know i did
that wrong now we can have an adult
conversation but to argue so you just
never could get over that aspect of i've
always felt women and then by me being
successful
women
always sabotaged the relationship
because they didn't believe
and they don't trust you whether they
didn't trust me or they didn't believe
they was i was actually dating them oh
okay so it was that insecurity when
you're successful when you're on the
road when you're tk kirkland yeah i mean
all that always plus i'm always going so
it wouldn't be fair to a woman right
because oh i'm always going like the
panthen was really a great thing for me
because after 37 years i was able to
stay home for the first time like i've
never been in one place you've always
been on the road man yeah always been on
the road killing it like the thing that
i tell people that even though you got
people who um went on to do good movies
and get famous
and they had the highs right right but
i've been consistent 37 years
well yeah we see a lot of people i'll
drive by the marquis at uh
flappers here in burbank or the improv
and i'll see somebody but i remember
that person from that movie in 99
yeah i've been consistent i won't go for
an audition unless it's handed to me
because i've been i'm a hustler so i
don't believe in wasting my time so i
never remember
i never went to the auditions to do
movies because back in the day i was you
know i was i was and i was in the
streets right and um
like when all my comedian friends was
coming up i was richer than them based
on loves the d.o.h you know i'm the one
that had the money so
but
um
the way society changed yeah sometimes i
want to go on social media with a
[ __ ] bag of money that [ __ ]
know like y'all ain't doing well [ __ ] is
getting it but my
discipline
right that's important kicks in it's
important to not give in to to your ego
thank you my my my my discipline that
[ __ ] happens to me all the time i'm like
man i want to just [ __ ] tell some
[ __ ] i just want to just do it
like [ __ ] i'm like every now and
then my show the bad ladies every now
and then my show you might i won't
show it but you might see me spinning
right right caught a glimpse of it
i might do that but i don't do this
to put you to get you locked up i'll get
you robbed uh how often do you work on
new material every day every [ __ ] two
or three minutes so when you're
touring because like obviously we'll see
uh comedians go to the comedy store and
work on their new [ __ ] yeah that they're
eventually gonna hit the road with right
for you is your is your live show always
evolving every day
and that's the difference for me most
convenience but that's once people see
me perform
you truly see who's really the best
comic that ever hit the mic right like
once you see me
because a lot of people don't have it in
them to do new material like no they
don't like it somebody's doing the same
material for six months
changes unlike like right now it's who
raised you but i don't even do who
raised you really that much no more you
know
my new thing is about um called um you
young [ __ ] don't know nothing about
you know such and such right and then i
used to have things go don't play me
play lotto you got better chances get
your ass in the car put your head out
the window cause i used to write titles
for
comedy like how somebody write a song
right
have you ever written for other
comedians no no no no no no everything
is for me because everything to me comes
from my heart because there are some
comedians who use writers people don't
yeah some do yeah some do and and a lot
of communities have bit off my stuff and
and flipped it but
back in the day uh i'm not the comedian
in the call someone said yo you stole my
[ __ ]
that happens a lot that's i think that's
petty too like no disrespect i don't
really [ __ ] with comedians i'm much
older than them and i'm a street [ __ ]
so
my my my way of thinking is different
like i don't really hang with me don't
go over your house
you know we ain't gonna hang out i see
you we'll have a drink for a minute but
i go on about my business because i'm 20
maybe 20 15 20 years older than you
and coming up hustling coming up getting
my education as a um college being an
athlete i just saw the world differently
so i always tell people that um
[Music]
i'm a businessman and comedy is my side
hustle hey we gotta stop the podcast man
real quick appreciate y'all for watching
uh really mean mean it subscribe like
leave a comment even if you're one of
those [ __ ] who leaves a comment
you're always interrupting the guests
cause it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
right because i've seen um ig comedians
that literally is one dude literally
your bit about uh some girls about to
graduate from high school right right
literally said that whole joke verbatim
and i called him out that [ __ ] happens a
lot it happens all the time all the
comedians watching you ever see somebody
biting someone else's [ __ ] call them
call them out because i make videos on
ig and every every now and then i say
like my boy tk would say who raised you
right yeah no i fee i do feel like
there's because there's such a
generation or like
demographic separation between people
who watch stand-up and people who are on
ig
or tick-tock comedians that there are
people who like uh patrice o'neil there
was some dude on youtube who stole his
whole [ __ ] for like a year and a half i
remember and because
it's a different world right right you
know finally people started to really
kind of hold this year and it's crazy
how
you can do that and feel like you
accomplish something it's a short nut it
is what it is man that's all the tick
tock is just cautious
in my style it's like mike epps was
saying one day he said you got to be
you can't really steal tk kirkland [ __ ]
because my shit's not recycled jokes
right my shit's like i actually have
lived it
you know like my [ __ ] is for real and if
you do it
you got to have a certain
swag or persona about you you know like
right now i'm talking about how i only
date
um married women and women who are
relationships because i know you hoes
ain't happy
they're the kind of [ __ ] i [ __ ] with
[ __ ] can't say that you know
you know and then i talk about how
and i said one of my [ __ ] i haven't
[ __ ] for years died during kovic let
me get out of here and i said
dodger and kovic
and um i said we had to you know
couldn't go to the funeral so you had to
have the [ __ ] on zoom
you know and i said i said this would
mean a lot of you young [ __ ] i
think you're placing i'm the type of
[ __ ] if i'm [ __ ] your wife or your
girl [ __ ] i can't [ __ ] your girl and
take out of the country go to turks and
caicos rome [ __ ] and come back and you
don't have any gifts i said that's
disrespectful i wasn't raised like that
i said if i'm [ __ ] your girl you
gonna get something when i come back so
the funeral
that we had on zoom
um the young lady died and they had all
her names up on the on the
on the computer so all of a sudden her
husband want to be sensitive on this day
this [ __ ] died right so at the funeral
you know because the mike is live he's
going i see him get up and he go walk
over to the funeral director
and he said hey um t.k kirkland is on
zoom
he's been having an affair with my wife
over 15 years is there any way we could
block them and the funeral director's
like look i don't block nobody i don't
even bond people so when he came back to
get a seat he took his jacket off
and threw it over the camera
now
people may not understand
but i bought that [ __ ] that jacket in
2005. can you imagine
can you imagine how i felt knowing
that's the jacket
that you broke through i bought you
[ __ ] you to have the nerve
thrown on the camera
disrespectful this really happened no i
just made it up
that's the thing like there's some
comedians that will say [ __ ] just out of
shock i believed every [ __ ] word but
the color is
having the ability to lure you in
see i'm a great storyteller 100
that's some real [ __ ] that's hilarious i
had you your undivided attention
man
yeah
and if people gonna watch it they're
gonna be like whoa yeah then that would
kill on stage oh yeah do it already oh
that's amazing yeah um you uh
we were talking off the camera a bit
about just some of the because you know
you're obviously a creative guy you're a
great writer
uh we're talking about how you're in the
ozark yes yes yes yes yeah you think
that's the great we're talking about 50
cents whole entire
power
50's just influencing other drug dealers
of the next generation
because what people see they they start
reacting right so 50 took something and
flipped it and he made whole star this
should be 50 stars in the reup that's
what it should be called right
and
um all shows are good and shout out to
50. i um
i used to introduce 50 on the ho on the
rough riders tour right oh back in the
day before when he got shot oh wow yeah
yeah that was like a early 50s that was
before junit yeah those columbia records
yeah columbia records yeah so um me and
him was good and to see what he's done
is just awesome so shout out to 50. come
on now um
with the tv show ozark
i get deep into tv and film so i look at
everything the scenery in the background
the dialogue
the casting director who
casts
that show or shows right because that
person so you can get two or three good
actors
but ozark everybody down to the bar
everybody down to who putting gas in the
car everybody who's walking by was
strategically
planned
so whoever did that was just did a
phenomenal job because there's no
weakness the only thing
that um bothered me is with ozark was
that um
marty
is always getting out of one situation
going right into somebody
and i build my life as finding the
solution so i can have peace of mind
right he's never got peace of mind he's
never
mind
so that's irritating to me because i'm i
teach my children that right right
what's the solution so we wouldn't have
a solution so at least i don't get
[ __ ] two days three days or a month i
want some peace of mind somewhere in
there mary's like [ __ ] have a
heart attack
yeah yeah it's crazy crazy
that's to you is is that that that's
your your goat tv show though the number
one yeah well i i'm mad that i got it
got it off on the first day i watched
the whole
season four in one day just got it out
the way just got out the way and i was
wondering if i was up to like seven
eight in the morning but man it was
worth it fire that's how interesting it
had yeah it's a great show it had me
on the edge of my seat and
um
i want to thank you my man for having me
on your show i want to thank you for um
great questions
a lot of people don't know
what to ask me or to talk to me about
and um i feel like you you talk to me
like
a man
to talk about man things that people
around the world
can use and apply to their life because
um even if we get 90 of people don't
understand that 10
is worth
well you know i think
anything these days people are very
uninterested in
the actual point as much as they're
interested in being mad exactly i
totally agree with you everyone wants to
be
emotional yes and the wild thing about
that is
you could be talking to somebody and
they agree with you 95 of the way if
the goal is um
we're in a very interesting place in
life you guys age group man brother
thank god you're married though you at
your age that that age group you're in
is in
in danger
hmm
i could see it that's 90 i just think in
general if we think about like this the
period of time we're in i think
what's weird about kind of
you know obviously four years of trump
that america was very much here and here
but with some of the covet stuff that's
been happening
overhearing over here starting to kind
of overlap on the it's just all insane
like i was thinking about this other day
like
years ago you never think of anybody
fighting on in the airplane
true it's going to a whole nother level
it's just anger people getting out the
car and shooting each other because of
one slight little mistake because you
cut a person off by accident because it
just happened wasn't like i was trying
to be rude
[ __ ] happens people beating each other
up for no reason
smash and grab
people coming in and breaking to get
jewelry
what that you can't sell that you risk
going to prison for
young kids um young rappers who are
dying at alarming rate more so than ever
before oh no it's it's the yeah the
hip-hop thing is is crazy right it's
insane we're losing people every young
dog
nipsey and all these people dying
because they got hey like millions of
people love you but only take one hater
to get you and most most of those people
are from where you're from yes
there's no hate that you're ever going
to get if you're successful than from
where you're from because those people
are like why wouldn't me right right
right it's like dr joe used to say we
used to be in the studio down in
torrance and he's always saying you
can't touch what you can't see
so what's the solution yeah you just
move out the way and you still can help
people but you ain't got to actually be
there don't be don't be too accessible
don't be too accessible and in the
proven point martin luther king malcolm
x
everybody who was those type of people
or if the government can get you your
own people get you so you got to stay
moving
real quick uh give us a story uh just
being on the road uh for that rough
riders tour obviously that's the rough
rider tour i'll tell you um
because what year was that that was what
99 98.99
the great thing about the rough rider
tour even to this day is um the respect
that everybody gives me
i remember one day um in miami walking
down my face aaron was with me when he
was in miami how baby in them and his
brother was just driving down the street
they pulled over so is this the rough
rider's cash money tour roughriders
catch money yeah yeah at that time rough
riders was the biggest [ __ ] and it was
cash i mean they were both they were
both dmx was the yeah right
it was it was just great so from dmx to
the rough ride like
like so in comedy when comedians say
they such and such
world to tell you that tk kirkland is
truly the man he you may not see him in
the movie but i did some things that no
other comic would truly have done i told
him some of the you hosted that tour so
i hosted that tour the hard like life
tour with jay-z you hosted the hard
knock life i was that was that was uh i
was 12 years old yeah i went close to
that method man and red man flying
around the air yep sure was wow
straight out of the compton tour
um
i've done it all also shout out
another guy who uh
alex thomas when i was a kid he hosted
the uh yeah
alex don't know he almost got fired on
that tour on the up and smoke tour
because dr drain was in detroit they was
gonna fire him
because they was my crew yeah yeah and
um they went in the back and what we
decided was as a no this first time ever
mentioned it i said no alex my man let
him hold that and then two weeks later i
had got the um cash cash money tour yeah
so that means i would've had all those
tours what was like backstage like in 99
98 with the rough riders and well here's
the thing
there was much respect but what the
problem was is when we put made men on
the concert on the tour
right you ever seen in them so when we
got to boston apparently the night
before dmx had a situation with a female
mm-hmm and i didn't notice you know
because when i hung out with everybody i
was my own guy right right so when we
come back to the um stadium
i'm hearing the commotion but i'm still
in my business
all of a sudden may men and the rough
riders
get into this brawl in boston backstage
in boston which is their hometown yes
and
nice i'm about right here knives is
going past me
like stabbing like nobody everybody
respect tk to the point that everybody's
fighting around me nobody's fighting no
people getting stabbed talking about
stabbed brother they was for real but
one thing i have to tell the world
you do not want to [ __ ] with the rough
riders
when i say
mostly all those people from may men
came out going to the hospital
they was the rough riders was prepared
for that fight and they took them they
were dmx like directly involved in this
it was just like entourage yeah
i don't think they know dmx wasn't
fighting
yeah but it it it went crazy i got mad
because on the tour we were about to hit
some of the biggest cities
in the country that i was popular in
like miami
and even they knew me at the improv
right they didn't see i wanted them to
see me on the cash money rough rider
tour it'd have been a whole and and if
you back in the day you could be in all
cities in the world but the most
beautiful women in the early late 90s
was in miami i still think that might be
the case still might be in miami brother
it was off the chain so
to experience all that um
[Music]
was just amazing on that tour and i tell
people to this day to see dmx perform
like oh there's a lot of great rappers
but to see dmx perform on stage by
himself is unbelievable what he was
capable of doing the way he captivated
crowds where he captivated by himself by
him you couldn't take your eyes off him
yeah i i mean listen man that was one of
that concert like the hard knock life
tour really kind of changed my life yeah
see i liked that because he was 12 years
that's amazing when he did those prayers
yep yep and quiet as kevin i always say
this like when dmx got off on stage on
the hard knock life tour
i i mean maybe stuck around for two or
three j records and then left right
right i was like well we came here to
see dms yeah yeah yeah shout out to jay
right volume 2 was going crazy at the
time but like yeah that's okay i got a
crazy jay-z story and i'm out i tell
people all the time that um
back in 1995 was 35 years old
and i threw this big party in harlem
and like i said i'm well connected with
the streets um young man named eric vine
zip um haitian jack all these guys who
wrote me shout out to haitian jack i'm
always gonna show him love
um
my people
hired his guys out of brooklyn to do my
birthday party
and um we've got the mink coats on we
got our cars outside we flossing yeah so
these guys are late
and my boy said yo they're here t you're
gonna let him put up his um [ __ ] them
[ __ ] and i got the coat on [ __ ] up
the champagne spilling hey late [ __ ]
my birthday party out insane
jay-z
jay-z
95 this is pretty reasonable doubt so
this is like
so i pulled him to the side and this we
didn't have credit cards and we had lots
of money in road man so peeled off 1500
and gave it to him said good show wow
and i tell people he took my i'm saying
he took my that was my seed money
and he flipped it and flipped it and
flipped it and became billionaire great
great jay-z thank you for everything
he's done for me too shout out to home
come on yeah him damon dash damn still
still killing it yeah
they always show me mad love always show
me man love so i always try to tell
those stories um even with r kelly you
know i told r kelly a lot in the 90s as
well and god bless his situation but i
will always show respect it's about what
he can expect for what he did for me
because he kept me working too like
there's no other other comedian that
worked more than me
nobody especially touring with touring
like that
musical artist yeah i'm talking about
from nwa
all the way to patty the bell
and you hosted these tours yes all the
way to the whispers wow all the way to
frankie beverly in may wow
yeah i'm talking about that kind of
stuff what was the difference between
like r kelly hosting r kelly tour it's a
totally different dynamic than going out
on the road with nwa yeah you're going
out on the road with dmx that's why i
tell congress you gotta have see i've
had the ability to switch up styles
true you that's versatility is very
important and anything there's a
difference between a comedian in the
emcee
um
oh yeah i've never heard comedian to
this day ever say emcee
and what that means is master ceremonies
it's hard to do that you got to know how
to be the master someone um what's the
guy that came over at def jam um gore
elon with the black hair
um
he over warner brothers now oh um
[ __ ] leo cohen leo yeah cohen he saw
me at the rough rider tour and i never
get what he said he said tk he said no
one knows how important your job is
so he said you have the ability to
control the real cause how about i want
to set that room up if i want to start a
riot i can start it right right
if i keep on learning people laughing so
one of the things that was phenomenal
was in new york city
and i kept telling the audience from the
very beginning hey i got some special
people i've been in this business a long
time y'all in for a treat tonight ladies
and gentlemen we keep bringing on
different acts
so i talked to the music guy off stage
said listen this is what we're going to
do you follow me and we're going to get
these [ __ ]
that go so playing doing this thing
right before cash money comes on i'll
come i said yo i've been telling you
over for an hour
did i be in this business people [ __ ]
with me they love me
and when i'm about to say these names
imagine these these people's big talk
about superstars at this time
i said ladies and gentlemen put your
hands together
for dr dre snoop dogg and eminem
and they play eminem's music from the
beginning
i had the tv people likes take
everything down like they was really
getting ready to come on snapchat
they was losing their mind i walk off
the stage
i'm talking about they losing their mind
and i come back on stage and say psych
hit them in my palm oh now if they
didn't love me
they'd they turned that [ __ ] out
but they loved me and when they was
clapping and laughing because i got them
i said put even baby because i was
coming out i said put your hands
together even at the show you said [ __ ]
i really thought them [ __ ] was here
real quick last thing when you were on
the road with kelly did you did how was
he as a dude because we always here
never i'm i'm i'm independent i never
rolled in even though i was a cash money
never rolled with them outside the
stadium even when i was with nwa
because i was i was much older right
than most of these guys so i moved like
a man so you really weren't around r
kelly enough to really kind of get up
never paying attention never went hung
out with them never got women even with
nwa when you see the movies and i'm
[ __ ] in the dressing room i mean this
hotel i was [ __ ]
just in your own way yeah i'm a player
i'm not [ __ ] wrong they they was kids
at that time they wasn't moving the way
i was moving right
i was moving i was already moving so
even when i come to the tours like i
remember um jay-z crews like because
every city winter i always had a bad
[ __ ] breathing on me they're like [ __ ]
every [ __ ] where we go you got a bad
[ __ ]
everywhere i went
every city i had still the case you're
still getting i still keep the batteries
on me the nice rotation but now i don't
i don't [ __ ] no more i snuggle with
[ __ ] i respect it yeah see i snuggled
is that from a choice or just from uh
like you're just tired i'm just tired
you know like i had the other night i
had a girl snuggling with me and she's
like tk you've been working out
like you're strong
you know you're holding me tight you
dick on my spine and
i
breathe i heard you still
i'm like can't
[Music]
that's why i hold you tight ck kirkland
lazy